[Musique]
126 voilà le nombre de candidatures de
femmes artistes amateurs enregistré pour
la 19e édition du Prix selimen organisé
par le département c'est en ce mercredi
8 mars date symbolique de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes que
s'est déroulée la cérémonie d'annonce
des lauréats dans les jardins de
l'artothèque à Saint-Denis en présence
de la vice-présidente Béatrice sigismo
et du rectorat on a de plus en plus
d'artistes
qui participent à ce à ce grand concours
avec
plein de thématies d'émotions de talent
et cette année on a eu 126
artistes qui nous ont proposé des
oeuvres et la partie aussi pour les
jeunes
puisque depuis 2016 les collégiens
participent au Grand Prix sévi-men et
cette année on a eu collège qui ont
participé c'est une réussite cette année
encore et on invite à tout à chacun qui
ne connaissait pas jusqu'à présent le
plus Célimène de se préparer pour
l'édition de mes 23 2024 peinture
sculpture ou encore photographique la
créativité des femmes réunionnaises a
été mise en lumière et quatre artistes
ont été récompensés pour leurs œuvres
saisissantes Catherine ragonet a reçu le
premier prix pour sa sculpture femme
multiple le deuxième prix a été attribué
à l'oeuvre Africa des Laura bennar le
troisième prix agustinier lazute maison
pour sa peinture énigme féminine le prix
spécial développement durable revient
lui à Jennifer baraka vidote pour son
oeuvre et un jour une femme une remise
de prix tout en émotion pour ses
lauréats depuis que j'ai commencé à
faire du modelage j'ai eu assez
rapidement des petits personnages
souvent féminins parfois masculin et là
pour le concours du coup j'ai
sélectionné plusieurs statuts qui
représentaient des femmes diverses dans
leur façon dans leur pose dans leur type
dans leur trait aussi dans la technique
employée il y en a qui sont recouvertes
des mailles d'autres qui sont en terre
cuite
presque crues il y en a d'autres qui
sont cuites et repassés avec des
couleurs elles ont toutes des couleurs
et donc des types différents et je
voulais représenter le la diversité
énorme et de tous les types féminins qui
est quelque chose de fascinant le prix
c'est l'hymen junior à lui était
attribué aux élèves du collège le comte
de Lille de saint Louis pour leur œuvre
intitulée le poids du collier métaphore
des clichés liés à la féminité
donc on a collaboré avec l'artiste
plasticienne Alice au cuite qui est venu
durant huit séances travail avec les
élèves et l'idée c'est de travailler
autour de la symbolique de la femme
qu'est-ce que la femme représente les
stéréotypes les clichés l'idée était que
chaque élève produit une réalisation en
argile la problématique c'est poser
comment on va relier chaque production
et donc le collier est apparu comme la
réponse la plus adaptée et en plus
autour on a travaillé autour de la
symbolique du collier donc objet de
féminité et en même temps le poids du
collier les chaînes etc de enfin tout ce
que ça peut représenter connoter
vis-à-vis de la femme voilà et de ses
droits aujourd'hui dans le monde cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes fut également l'occasion de
présenter la bande dessinée 5 femmes 5
destins qui donnent vie à quelques
figures féminines emblématiques de
l'histoire de la Réunion comme Juliette
Dodu ou encore Célimène godieu
l'inspiratrice de cette cérémonie
[Musique]